Luke here at the outdoor boys YouTube
channel and today we're hunting toddlers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey welcome to another episode of
outdoor voice and I'm out here in the
driveway working on restoring a
battle-axe but unfortunately it's
raining on me and we have had so much
rain lately but I'm gonna call it I'm
not going to be doing this in the rain
so I'm gonna think I'm gonna do
something fun with the boys I think I'm
going to hunt them what I've got here is
the demolisher two in one from nerf I
bought this thing for another video
we're doing and I think I'm gonna use it
to hunt my children and I shoot it's
battery-operated so it's got this fan
you pull the trigger and the semi-auto
and then it's got this grenade launcher
they pump and it shoots a grenade stores
another one back here in the stock I
want to mount a GoPro on this thing I
think what I just need to do is grind
this part flat and then stick one of
these adhesive GoPro mounts right there
I think we're ready go get some kids so
tonight there's a new bedtime routine
and the bedtime routine is going to be
about you girls feeling very safe and
secure in your own bedrooms
Oh Nathan you want to drink your milk
too bad
go to bed you are drinking milk to
remember Nathan remember daddy loves you
very much
now go to sleep
[Music]
all right guys now you guys gotta be
good for Joey here she's gonna be
babysitting you okay Zoey do you want to
hunt the children yeah just you remember
shoot him in the eyes otherwise it
doesn't hurt alright there's more rounds
in the garage if you need them okay if I
told you missed yeah hold on Tom I think
there's something wrong with
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the lie detector test determined that
was a lot not a good shot
[Music]
[Music]
yes makeup you want to turn okay here we
go we've got a full clip for you all
right kids
Mama's gonna start hunting you everyone
at home if we can get 5,000 likes on
this video
Becca will shoot Jakob in the face of
the nerf gun
nope no no wait we're not doing that hi
Tommy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for watching guys we hope you had
a great time and enjoyed this video if
you'd like to see more great videos from
the outdoor boys YouTube channel don't
forget to click Subscribe and don't
forget to check out our trapping
toddlers video if you want to learn how
to humanely trap and relocate children
we've got to be there just for that so
thanks for watching we put out new
videos every Saturday thanks for
watching we hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you'd like to see more great
videos from the outdoor boy's YouTube
channel don't forget to click subscribe
we put out new videos every week and
don't forget to hit that Bell button so
you'll get notified when we put out
another great video